in the 90s on Fleet Street but we used
to drink and drink and drink and it was
because that there's not that much to do
right taking writing a piece it's a
couple of hours but you when you in the
days when you went to an office you had
eight hours to fill so you get in go to
a conference write a paragraph do your
intro then go to the pub for three hours
and and and get battered come back at 4
and then it's exciting trying to get it
done by 5:30 when you can hardly see
with one hand over your eye and and the
keyboard and that's the whole profession
sort of built up around that take away
the booze and you could hardly say
papers are more interesting now are they
I don't know what they're doing